rescue workers are on alert in Yosemite
National Park where a cold and wet
winter has created a dangerous condition
in the Merced River posing a hazard to
visitors Jonathan Vigliotti got a very
wet and close-up view at the Yosemite
search and rescue teams Yosemite Merced
River is running so fast rescue crews
say people who fall in have about 15
seconds to get out or risk being swept
away those people who get rescued
weren't planning on getting wet
I think they underestimate a few things
about the water the force the speed of
the water and the current fueled by the
West's record mountain snowpack now
melting and filling up lakes and streams
at unprecedented levels right as people
are heading to the water to cool off and
you've got to assert yourself within
that situation to save yourself because
we're a long way behind trying to help
whose Motlow is the team's senior
instructor that will be fatalities
generally associated with water
incidents two-thirds of the operations
they go on with water a body recovers
over the top hand comes through this
point here we suited up to experience
search and rescues rigorous training
firsthand I'm a pretty strong swimmer
and I've gotta say this is pretty
intimidating I swam into the strong
current and became part of this rescue
drill
[Music]
rescue teams only have one shot to grab
hold of me
early in the water for putting on to a
few seconds but within that time you
lose your energy so fast and it's so
cold it sucks the air community thank
you breathing really hard despite the
dangers visitors are flocking to
national parks with phones in hand to
document their time in the forest first
social media but park ranger James Cox
says getting distracted could be deadly
we would use a lot of judgement and
awareness around the edge of a cliff and
a large fall we got to bring that same
awareness and judgment to the river so
we won't get caught off guard
life-saving advice in dangerous waters
when every second counts for CBS this
morning Saturday Jonathan Vigliotti
Yosemite National Park you know you
think about the dangers of just
distracted walking anywhere when you're
in those conditions nature can be fierce
it's a watch it's a huge deal there at
bridal veil falls in Yosemite when the
rocks get wet you can slip on them it's
a huge deal in a lot of the national
parks people going now some can be
accidents but some going to places to
take selfies where it might not be the
best idea to take a selfie whether it's
the Grand Canyon somewhere else just so
many accidents just over the last few
weeks alone